il avait donc lipospadias qui est une
courbure anormale du pénis surtout en
érection et Catherine de Médicis avait
un utérus rétroversé donc effectivement
bonsoir est-ce que vous connaissez Lara
Fabian qu'est-ce
que c'est pas grave
je pouvais
si vous deux achetez mon lit
[Applaudissements]
Sandrine
c'est son premier dit c'est la première
fois qu'elle chante elle a beaucoup de
chance parce que c'est Alain Souchon qui
lui a qui lui a fait les musiques
comment ça va princesse ça va très bien
je suis entre deux chanteuses je suis
fière de chanter mais à la fin oui je
peux chanter un peu vous savez
[Applaudissements]
est une Altesse Royale alors comment
faut-il vous appeler
Janine
on doit vous dire quoi princesse chez
nous
on dit Madame madame voilà ça va c'est
très simple c'est cool je m'appelle
vraiment Marie-Christine alors si vous
êtes très très souple
Marie Christine
[Applaudissements]
votre mari est le cousin quand même et
le cousin de la reine d'Angleterre
alors vous partagez votre temps entre
votre appartement de du palais de
Kensington et puis vous avez un petit
manoir dans le Cher
ou vous cultivez votre passion de
l'histoire oui voilà vous êtes déjà
écrit deux best-sellers historiques
des best-sellers historiques
et vous publiez aujourd'hui chez la tête
la lune et le serpent
alors le pitch est très simple c'est
l'histoire d'un ménage à trois le roi de
France Henri II à l'époque où il est
dauphins puis ensuite quand il est roi
alors Henri Dès c'est le fils de
François 1er qui a été toute sa vie fou
d'amour de Diane de Poitiers qui avait
18 ans de plus que lui il faut bien le
dire il avait été marié pour des raisons
d'État disons par son père François 1er
à Catherine de Médicis qui était une
parente du pape pour arranger les
affaires de François 1er en Italie voilà
mais mais lui la personne qui l'aimait
c'était Diane de Poitiers ça ressemble
un peu à Camilla exactement
c'est l'histoire qui aurait pu avoir
Camilla Lady Di
tu as raison sauf que là Camilla est
belle et Lady est moche c'est l'histoire
non mais c'est vrai non mais
si princesse dans l'histoire c'est un
peu pareil
18 ans
de 19 ans il y avait 101 ans
c'est vrai que il est il est héritier du
trône c'est c'est vrai il est héritier
du trône il a une maîtresse qui a 18 ans
de plus que lui bon et il a une femme
qui a son âge bon la différence c'est
qu'effectivement Camilla est moche et
les viviers étaient belles alors que là
c'est l'inverse franchement honnêtement
de tout parce que à l'époque je dois
faire très attention que je dis à
l'époque Henri le roi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
chez nous les tours je vous explique
parce que avec 14 ans Henri était obligé
de marier Catherine 14 ans et le jour
qui sont rencontrés le jour le soir même
ils étaient obligés de consommer cette
mariage devant 20 ans de la cour oui
c'est pas drôle de tout c'était pas tout
le même chose non parce que c'était
business business mariage était business
c'est une autre chose non il faut dire
aussi quand même il faut dire aussi
quand même princesse que le futur roi le
futur Henri II souffrait d'hypo spa Dias
[Rires]
[Musique]
qui est une courbure anormale du pénis
surtout en érection et Catherine de
Médicis avait un utérus rétroversé donc
effectivement
avoir un héritier évidemment puisque tu
imagines
elle se gavait Catherine de Médicis la
petite reine se gâcher de potions
magiques alors écoute bien ce qu'elle
prenait du lait de jument avec du sang
de lapin de l'urine de brebis et des
centres de crapaud donc elle prenait ça
pour être pour être très simple elle
avait autour du ventre une ceinture de
poils de bouc trempée dans du tremper
dans du lait d'ânesse elle était
d'origine portugaise
on dirait une phrase
et donc et donc ils arrivaient pas
malgré tout ces trucs là ils arrivaient
pas et un jour Diane donc Ménage à 3
Diane qui avait quand même donc 18 ans
de plus que que le futur roi qui était
sa maîtresse dans
sa mort à 67 ans elle lui conseille la
levrette
[Rires]
Sandrine évidemment
bien qu'elle avait un enfant chaque
année pour le prochain 10 ans et voilà
voilà tu vois comme quoi des fois il
suffit de retourner le problème
alors c'est extraordinaire dans le livre
de la princesse de Kent c'est qu'il y
avait des soirs où Catherine était
fécondable évidemment il avait certains
j'ai déjà la méthode originaux avant
l'heure et quand elle était fécondable
évidemment Diane de Poitiers laissez le
roi aller dans la couche de Catherine
pour qu'il fasse son petit truc là comme
ça on le vrai donc et après il revenait
et puis il redormait quand même avec
elle toute la nuit mais un moment
Catherine de Médicis s'est mise à aimer
Henri II et elle avait fait un trou dans
le plancher t'imagines pour regarder
comme ça c'est extraordinaire si c'est
fou c'est l'histoire c'est comment vous
allez trouver tout ça c'est parce que
les ambassadeurs
à côté d'elle alors la dame l'honneur a
expliqué à la cour qu'est-ce qui est
arrivé et les ambassadeurs écrit écrit
alors on trouve tout ça dans les
correspondances des ambassadeurs
alors ce qui est incroyable c'est que
Diane de Poitiers donc la vieille
maîtresse s'occupait des enfants elle
était chargée de ce que vous appelez la
pouponnière royale c'est-à-dire qu'elle
s'occupait des enfants de la reine quoi
mais malgré ça il est quand même
beaucoup de haine ça c'était la façade
elle avait Catherine de Médicis elle
avait une vraie haine pour Diane de
Poitiers et il avait une devise elle est
tombée amoureuse du roi parce que ça
c'était pas normal enfin on se marier
parce que c'était affaire d'État n'est
ce pas c'était tout à fait organisé
mais elle est tombée amoureuse c'est
pour ça que elle était jaloux
normalement pas du tout
la devise de Catherine de Médicis
c'était haïté et attendez
18 ans
[Rires]
évidemment que que le roi Henri II soit
mort pour gouverner et pour virer Diane
évidemment alors diane était très belle
son secret de beauté c'était quoi
alors beaucoup de secrets mais moi j'ai
essayé quelques-unes voilà et un de ces
secrets de dormir assis oui comme ça sur
les coussins comme ça on fait pas des
plis alors moi j'ai essayé ça de pendant
six mois mon mari dans un autre pièce
chambre parce qu'il pouvait pas
alors tout ce qui est arrivé j'avais des
noirs sous mes yeux parce que je pouvais
pas dormir comme ça chaque nuit mais
elle se lève très tôt on déteste très
très tôt cela avait de l'eau très très
froide monter à cheval pendant trois
heures
rentrer manger dormir très difficile
c'est vrai que c'est une époque
extraordinaire
tout de suite comme des moustiques
votre mari le cousin de la de la reine
d'Angleterre donc mais vous vous êtes
une très très bonne famille d'une
famille autrichienne donc vous êtes
votre père et baron non
je descends de Catherine Hedia vous
savez ça c'est marqué regarde regarde
ma mère alors avant de vous consacrer à
l'histoire
Marie-Christine il faut vous appeler
Marie-Christine maintenant non princesse
tous les deux alors donc Marie-Christine
si je vais me permettre avant de vous
intéresser à l'histoire vous avez
beaucoup voyagé notamment en Afrique
parce que votre père avait des intérêts
comme on disait à l'époque au Mozambique
voilà une ferme un peu comme canne Dixon
alors il y a une histoire incroyable qui
vous est arrivé quand vous étiez plus
jeune donc un jour vous décidez d'aller
rejoindre votre père au Mozambique vous
arrivez au cap et pour aller du Cap donc
qui est en Afrique du Sud au Mozambique
qui est en face de Madagascar vous voyez
où c'est à gauche après température
pour aller au Mozambique vous choisissez
de prendre un autobus
vous aviez quel âge à l'époque 17 17 ans
mais l'autobus c'est pour les noirs
alors je me mets au soleil parce que
c'était été beaucoup beaucoup et j'avais
de très longues cheveux en ce temps là
et je l'ai fait noir
parce que j'ai des yeux clairs j'étais
obligé de dire que j'étais moitié non
vous partez dans cet autobus donc
maquillée voilà tu imagines trois
semaines de voyage et un moment vous
êtes mordu par un singe et vous avez
votre votre doigt qui enfle énormément
[Rires]
[Musique]
et donc pendant 4 jours vous êtes entre
la ville et la mort parce que ça
s'infecte terriblement tu sais les
morsures de singe et donc ces gens-là
et donc les les Noirs là-bas en Afrique
du Sud font des incantations magiques
pendant quatre jours et ce qui est
extraordinaire et c'est très beau
l'histoire c'est que le bus attend
que vous soyez guéri pour repartir
dans cette histoire alors ce voyage
montre que vous n'êtes pas raciste que
vous êtes vraiment prête à aller vivre
comme ça pendant trois semaines dans
l'autobus avec les Noirs au lieu de
prendre un moyen de je peux laver
beaucoup et alors il y a une chose une
question que je dois vous poser quand
même vous avez un problème là il y a
quelques temps en mai 2004 dans un
restaurant à New York j'ai une
altercation avec des Noirs où vous êtes
montré assez assez virulente avec eux et
vous leur avez demandé de parler moins
fort et ensuite je leur avais dit vous
devriez retourner dans vos colonies
c'est pas vrai c'est tout il y avait un
publiciste là ils ont inventé l'histoire
que je peux faire ils ont eu beaucoup de
publicité pour leurs clients
mettre les pendules à l'heure comme on
dit chez nous est-ce que c'est vrai que
vous avez défendu le prince Harry quand
il s'est habillé en Asie
vraiment défendu il m'a demandé comment
ça peut arriver je ne sais pas mais s'il
portait un
frencho
je pense qu'il y avait pas un si grande
à faire de presse mais malgré que ça
c'est une signe de Stala Staline
et pogrom et les choses affreux
simplement même si le résultat c'est
d'un côté Auschwitz c'est de l'autre
côté le goulag malgré tout quand même au
départ l'ambition des communistes
n'était pas la même que celle des nazis
je pensais que c'est aussi très très
grave très grave les goulags les pauvres
c'est grave et beaucoup de morts mais
j'ai pas vraiment défendu j'ai essayé de
expliquer mais je crois qu'il y a pas
une explication est-ce qu'il y a pas
sérieusement est-ce qu'il y a pas dans
la famille royale britannique quand même
une tradition le prince de Galles par
exemple celui qui a épousé Miss Simpson
il était quand même très favorable à
Hitler quand même je sais pas c'était
avant mon temps je vous prêterai les
livres alors vous savez chez Thierry ce
sont des questions que l'étiquette me
laisse pas répondre ouais alors vous
pouvez répondre sur votre père ça c'est
plus facile
votre père c'est vrai qu'il a été membre
du parti nazi en tant qu'autritien oui
tout le monde
en Allemagne était obligé d'être membre
de parti tout le monde était mais il n'a
pas fait quelque chose n'a rien fait
de trop vieux pour l'armée
et parce qu'il était dans le premier
guerre mondiale
avec vous en même temps c'est que bon
vous avez fait ce voyage en Afrique et
tout qui montre encore une fois à quel
point vous n'êtes pas raciste et votre
votre fille Gabriela qui s'appelle
ella en fait elle est là elle est elle
est fiancée avec un Indien
pas fiancé mais je voudrais bien parce
que le charmant les adorable mais c'est
toujours les journalistes il écrit
fiancé quand ils sont il sort ensemble
et il est très adorable et très beau
alors il est fantastique mais ils sont
pas fiancés
mais je pense pas trop à ces choses
j'écris je me je me cache ma tête dans
l'histoire et vous écrivez bien et en
plus d'être beaucoup de conférences
c'est votre temps à faire des
conférences sur l'histoire dans le monde
entier
alors dites moi camilia et Charles vont
se marier vous allez leur faire quoi
comme cadeau de mariage il a demandé pas
de cadeau de personne
à fondue un truc
halogène
c'est bien non interview mariage
princier
le mariage de Charles et Camilla est-ce
que vous avez été invité oui est-ce que
vous allez y aller est-ce que vous avez
déjà pensé à la tenue que vous allez
mettre oui je vais mettre quelque chose
que j'aime dans mon
petit robe bleue là
je l'adore
est-ce que quand on est prince on a le
droit de venir aux princesses on a le
droit de venir avec son caméscope
est-ce que vous pensez que Charles avant
de se marier va enterrer sa vie de
garçon
enterrer sa vie de garçon
se faire recoller les oreilles
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on fait la chenille dans les
mariages princiers
c'est une petite où tout le monde se
prend par la terre américaine
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous allez manger du couscous
royal ou c'est pas prévu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'espère un jour
vous voulez sur la bouche princesse avec
la langue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi vous devez rencontrer
raconter une histoire drôle
[Applaudissements]
alors alors il y avait du sébug
il y avait un voleur qui a regardé
depuis longtemps maison et quand il a vu
que les gens sont partis il est entrée
par fenêtres French Windows il entre
dans la maison
c'est tout à fait noir dans la maison
il touche un canapé
de canapé très lentement et tout un coup
il y a un bruit un voit très très fort
qui dit je peux le dire en anglais
je peux te voir et Jésus peut entendre
non
je peux t'entendre
[Applaudissements]
Jésus peut te voir
il se cache tout de suite il reste là
mais rien ne se passe il se lève il se
met encore très lentement très lentement
le canapé et de nouveau
je peux t'entendre et je peux te voir
très très fort
il descend de nouveau coeur il prend
parce que rien ne se passe un tout petit
à
dupechland
est là il y a dans un cas je me
perroquet il dit oh mon dieu vous êtes
seulement un perroquet le perroquet dit
oui c'est vrai
je suis seulement perroquet mais Jésus
c'est une Rottweil
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu